[Música]
quiero proponerles un pequeño ejercicio
quiero que presten atención a las
imágenes que les voy a mostrar y que en
base a mis afirmaciones elabore una
conclusión para ustedes mismos
soy padre de una nena de 12 años y a
ella le dejó ir a lugares llenos
desconocidos
allí ella puede entablar conversaciones
con cualquier persona
pero no solo con personas de su misma
edad sino con adultos de cualquier edad
ahí ella
va sola y sin que yo la acompaña
y en las conversaciones que tienen sin
importar con quién yo no estoy presente
no me digan a qué conclusión llegaron
aunque imagino pero sí déjenme decirles
algo la mayoría de ustedes hace lo mismo
que yo acabo de escribir
tengo que reconocer también que hice
trampa con las imágenes que les mostré
por lo que déjenme repetir las mismas
afirmaciones pero esta vez con las
imágenes correctas como les dije soy
padre de una nena de 12 años y ella la
dejó asistir a lugares llenos
desconocidos
allí ella puede hablar con cualquier
persona cuenta hablar cualquier tipo de
conversación
y no solo con personas de su misma edad
sino con personas de cualquiera con
adultos
a esos lugares ella va sola y sin que yo
lo acompañe en las conversaciones que
ella sostiene sin importar con quién o
de qué tema yo no estoy presente
como se habrán dado cuenta de lo que yo
estoy hablando desde la vida digital de
los chicos
o muchos sabrán
la mayoría de las aplicaciones servicios
digitales y demás tienen algún tipo de
restricción de edad para utilizarlos
siendo en su mayoría a los 13 años
ellos simplemente mintiendo con la edad
pueden utilizarlo de todas formas pero
problema esta es que mucha gente cree
que esa restricción tiene algo que ver
con su madurez o con el estar listos
para utilizar dichos servicios y la
verdad es que un chico por más que esté
cerca de los 13 años no está lo
suficientemente maduro para entablar una
conversación con un adulto que su único
objetivo es engañarlo
el hecho que los chicos tienen una
facilidad para con la tecnología que
nosotros nunca tuvimos nos distorsiona
nuestra propia realidad creemos que
están seguros él sabe lo que hace
la verdad es que es muy loco si nosotros
pensamos que nosotros creamos que van a
estar seguros en ese entorno digital en
el cual nosotros mismos los adultos
estamos sujetos a tantos problemas a
tantos riesgos noticias falsas fraudes
robe información extorsión
y tantos otros eran un chico no tiene
una tarjeta de crédito y por lo tanto
ser estafado y por eso es que la mayoría
de los riesgos a los que están sujetos
tienen que ver con su integridad sexual
se cree además que el entorno digital es
solo eso y que no tiene nada que ver con
la vida real
y un abuso por más que sea a través de
una plataforma digital es un abuso de
todas formas
es importante que sepan que todo
intercambio de fotos videos
inclusive conversaciones también pueden
constituir un abuso contra la integridad
sexual de un chico
y esto se agrava más aún cuando se
gestan encuentros en ese mundo digital
que luego se hacen realidad se concretan
en el mundo real
en el 2013 se aprobó en nuestro país la
ley de gruma por el cual se pena a
cualquier adulto que mediante cualquier
tipo de plataforma o servicio digital se
ponga en contacto con un menor para
cometer un abuso un delito contra su
integridad sexual
seguramente estarán de acuerdo conmigo
que un gran paso a nivel sociedad y que
era 100% necesaria
sin embargo considero que como toda ley
que penn una conducta reactiva y que no
implica que ellos están seguros creo que
ninguno de los que estamos aquí podemos
llegar a pensar que un chico un niño va
a estar seguro simplemente porque hay
una ley que pueda penar al abusador
y piensen un segundo lo que yo acabo de
decirles pero con un pequeño ejemplo
quién de nosotros dejaría hoy una
bicicleta una calle sin candado el robo
está penado sin embargo eso no nos hace
ni ser ni ni ni sentir ni creer que
estamos seguros
pero no me malinterpreten consideró que
la ley era 100% necesaria sólo que como
todo mecanismo punitorio es reactivo
nosotros nosotros somos los responsables
de cuidar a nuestros chicos
y eso me lleva a la siguiente pregunta
cómo hacemos qué hacemos los problemas
el acceso
y la respuesta es no la vida social de
un chico es muy importante y sobre todo
un algo que es clave que es el sentido
de la pertenencia del chico que se
sienta parte de
y como digo pertenencia no me refiero a
tener algo que tiene el otro que yo
quiero sino que debemos entender que hoy
en día gran parte de la vida social de
ellos pasa a través de las plataformas y
servicios digitales
para entender esto déjeme darle un
pequeño ejemplo una pequeña anécdota en
las conversaciones con el pediatra de
nuestra hija años atrás charlamos
respecto a que un chico no debería tener
acceso a un celular hasta los 11 años
obviamente que no utilice redes sociales
pasados los 13 y todo esto tenía sentido
si consideramos lo que yo les comenté
anteriormente sin embargo en las últimas
conversaciones charlamos de sentido a la
pertenencia qué pasa si nuestro hijo es
el único que no tiene un celular y por
lo tanto es el único que no está en el
grupo de chat de los amigos del curso
y esto aplica para todo tipo de
tecnologías qué pasa si nuestro hijo no
tiene el último juego al que todos se
juntan a jugar
como ven es bastante complicado es
complejo el tema porque por un lado si
les prohibimos el acceso los estamos
cortando socialmente pero por otro si se
lo permitimos los exponemos a gran
cantidad de riesgos por lo que vuelvo a
mi pregunta cómo hacemos qué hacemos se
acuerdan cuando les inicie la charla
es una analogía con un parque de
diversiones y si lo analizamos un parque
duraciones está pensado está diseñado
para los chicos porque están ahí que se
diviertan sin embargo ninguno de
nosotros los dejaría solo porque sabemos
los riesgos a los que están
asociados dejarlo solo
y eso es justamente lo que tenemos que
hacer tenemos que evitar dejarlos solos
tenemos que acompañarlos y tenemos que
involucrarnos
pero esto nos empuja al siguiente
problema
como lo hacemos como lo hacemos si no
tenemos la facilidad que tienen ellos
para con la tecnología y mucho menos
sabemos cuáles son todas las
aplicaciones que ellos utilizan las que
se ponen de moda
déjenme darles un pequeño ejemplo
personal hace 15 años que médico
ciberseguridad inclusive confunde una
empresa que desarrolla soluciones de
tecnología para empresas y gobiernos es
decir todo lo que hago
tiene que ver con la tecnología
sin embargo les tengo que reconocer que
me costó trabajo entender la diferencia
entre instagram y snapshot snap gratis
music y lo mismo con un sinfín de
aplicaciones que ellos usan
y es ahí donde me surgieron las mismas
preguntas que se deben hacer ustedes que
redes sociales utilizan para que usan
esta otra aplicación para qué sirve
se puede considerar un juego una red
social
el problema es que no tenemos ni vamos a
tener todas las respuestas a estos temas
entonces como nos acercamos si estamos
tan lejos de las tecnologías que ellos
utilizan
la forma que encontramos nosotros con
nuestra hija no fue por medio de
prohibir sino de acercarse pero por
sobre todo de entender cada una de esas
aplicaciones ella cada vez que va a
instalar una nueva aplicación o se va a
registrar en un nuevo servicio digital
se sienta con nosotros y nos explica
para que lo va a usar como para qué
sirve como lo usan sus amigos y en base
a eso que nosotros entendemos tratamos
de aconsejarla en base a
lo que entendemos
de los peligros que podría estar sujeto
acercándonos y felicitando la cuando
tiene por ejemplo nuevos seguidores es
como fomentamos en ella que nos venga a
contar sus logros en las plataformas
digitales
aconsejando la piel y evitar prohibir o
asustar es cómo generamos nosotros en
ella que nos vengo a consultar cuando
tiene dudas pero por sobre todas las
cosas como la contacta un extraño
involucrándonos es como nosotros
logramos evitar que ella esté sola en
ese mundo digital
entonces van a seguir dejando solos a
sus chicos en un lugar lleno de
desconocidos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]